so we're gonna do this podcast SMRs
it's this ah this podcast is project by
headspace get going on the way to a
happier stress-free lifestyle with
guided meditation via the headspace app
it's just ten minutes guys you download
the headspace app you plug in your
headphones and you're guided the less
stress and less anger less frustration
in your life take the take 10 program
for free right now guys go to head
space.com slash Jenna Julianne to get
started that's headspace / Jenna Julia
oh that's nice I like that
so guys what we did is we gathered a
couple things with this week first so I
guess what we will do is take turns
doing items Oh that make noises that we
think you might want to hear so yeah you
want to go do you have any things I
don't
so is this an appropriate podcast to do
like Julian's daddy heavy breathing
right now just I'll never get out of the
system everything is untwist people say
Julien breathe on me focus I breathe
really have you I'm focused so um anyway
that's Marple he's not playing along
with it tomorrow are you ready for my
first item yes I am it's that sounds
like like a like an intro movie you know
like that with your daddy
well I'll try something's happening down
here Omega something's happening
I've rolled over the corn no it's Julian
panicking
yeah I do
what is that it sounds like something on
is it sound like oh that's cool okay I
don't like that took me out of the
relaxed mode my next one actually I
don't know if this this is being maybe
the birds which we can leave this going
I want to let a couple more matches now
because I really like that noise
it sounds like a rock hey that's not my
garage that's why I love about as far as
I can get your tape sounded like
something like a plane but it's [ __ ]
tape experience guys just close your
eyes for a second okay and just picture
all night it's it's snowing outside
you're with your dad here with Yuri by
yourself you're bundled up at home in
your Kegel Eleni just all you want to do
is light a fire find some matches you
can't find that later so you get the
matches walk over to the fireplace like
this one this one is kind of good love
to it so you pull it out and then
suddenly you're warm
I just I'm a good storyteller right and
it's now an appropriate time to say it's
glad it's like it's legend flea has hard
to read out by this because this is
something new to us as much as it might
be new to you I flagged down already
I'm super deeper like absolutely I like
it though basically I like the fact that
we are we we were just we're driving
down podcast
our sedan probably 35 miles of calendula
and here we are
it was heinous fork in the road would we
never see we're thankful this is a SMR
road we've never been in it looks a
little gravy let's try it out so we're
taking a little different route this
week and get back on the main road
eventually but right now why not take
the little scenic there's a lot of
clouds over there we can get some bull
done throw Stratus or
[ __ ]
oh my god you're right you're right okay
but this thing let's get to the side
make it better okay I think we're doing
this why - its house - if I was too much
I have posted no guard
I don't want to draw sharpie on it as I
think that's also
sounds like you're like summoning a
demon so it sounds like a power washer
you ever seen those houses like they
power wash porches and stuff I don't
know I am my spurt that's me whispering
should I die no because you might do
something I don't
all right oh that's like my second
favorite channel it was so good
my first favorite channels probably vice
land then TV Jenna from vice made for
you guys with awesome new shows airing
right now if I slammed I let's go check
it out well on your local listings for
Vice Landing they have awesome new
content advice makes some of the most
entertaining mole content out there they
do documentary style a new feature style
there's this one show I talked about it
before it's called balls deep it's on
Wednesdays at 8:00 on Vice land that
specific diamond this guy goes around
and just learns different walks of life
by immersing himself in it and it's very
very like viscerally it's in there
and it's just it's very very cool to
watch so go check out Vice land right
now guys if you uh if you want something
to watch because Netflix is slow but you
do run out of stuff and vice lands it's
on Channel brought to you by vice with
very very cool London and ball sleep is
just one of the shows there's many other
close shows that are on that there's
about stand-up comedians about gays also
as a different things like what's uh
what's Titian there's a cool show going
on you don't even my hairdresser asked
me if I'd see my vacation that's the one
yes it looks really [ __ ] cool alright
so guys so qualify slant right now guys
check it out
the channel launched last month we
actually podcasted the day it launched
so just really cool Janna's gonna
swallow because she's so excited about
Iceland thank advice lab for sponsoring
us and guys please go check them out
thanks the podcasts free for you also be
the new sponsor this week guys it's
called the home chef basically home chef
and gets you the ingredients you need to
cook the meals you want delivered to
your door okay and what's cool about
home chef is that they have a lot of
options they have gluten-free options
they have low calorie low carb options
vegetarian options things that you
wouldn't normally be able to get with
this type of service they can get you
surprised right now you can go to home
chef dot-com /jj and use go to JJ that
check out to get $20 off your own chef
water guys the meals end up being around
10 dollars a meal and what you're
getting fresh ingredients without having
a shop that's a damn good deal so please
make sure you check out some home chef
guys even just for the $20 off you can
try it out they have awesome meals like
maple miso glazed salmon with Brussels
sprouts guys come on this
chef Julian do you want me to pressure
here No
yes that one's really soothing that one
sounds like the beach
let me to me again my fair mom I can do
this turn your phone on side let's turn
on start up the volume let's turn it
down let's press the home button
let's do force touch oh yes please like
that oh that one's really subtle
anyway what's your I know you had
imagined well you can hear the gas get
closer okay that's so close what would
it sound like if you lived in Mike on
fire this is a woman struggling I'm
gonna get an ice cube
Julianne's beard oh you like it
no that's your weight can i unbutton
what are you things fun not as a grape
just oh no it's not selling [ __ ] oh I'm
very handsome they're making too much
noise oh oh oh okay okay
there's no assault going on guys show up
for work on Monday morning I'll tired
get some caffeine but you know what
gotta get started with the day so might
as well get to work it sounds a week but
this is my favorite band
wait I'm gonna go again
it sounds weak yeah I'm saving the best
for last
I'm saving my bed's got some mints Oh
flies out in a cloud freshness
that's the sound of a man on fresh
breath okay really wife I have to say
this I discovered there's a YouTube
channel where I [ __ ] sits and looks
at the camera smiling it's called
sitting and smiling for four hours and
time each video and he's made over 180
[ __ ] videos what that exists that guy
is our species he is one of us he does
that I don't know is it lit yeah oh okay
I love the sound of unsealing
it's really good it's it's a little
startling that's even more startling
yeah
one more one more one more - should I go
yeah I'll go right yes don't you want a
better guess what this is but this I
save this relies because I feel like
it's gonna sound the most satisfying
it's a sticker oh the podcast this is
actually the Twitter tweet sticker but I
just figured like a sticker peeling off
of its like when you get a new
electronic anyway that was my that was
my yeah that was my game-changer you
ready for this oh god you're handsome
okay it looks like sunblock I think we
should weigh strange eyes right now
you're ruining a pie we had a good time
and you're ruining it was cool noises
moderation and your okay let's breathe
yeah you have to move your face down so
your ears all right I was just trying to
sing some [ __ ] Jackson it's easy as
one-two-three ABC Q and me baby you and
me girl that was the wrong weird anthem
at you can't take it I'll be July 2 you
get X Y C let's do it again a B's
freestyle as how we jacob with the
forest hold on I gotta fix my shirt it
hurts because I'm covered in lotion you
you know we had a five going in your
room
Wow hopefully this was entertaining for
you guys oh no I like that one um thank
you guys for hanging out with us and
thank you for letting us do something
new this week we are we just experiment
a little fun so you got something out of
this and I had fun this sounded fun I
feel like we have the opportunity to do
a zoom our mics Jen talking to it but
we'll be back to speaking normally next
week we promise or will we
no I promise me well we or will we yes
likewise
really quick I just want you guys to
know that if you missed any of the
sponsor information we link and put all
the information of all the sponsors
stuff below in the description we really
appreciate you guys check that stuff out
because it makes the podcast free for
you guys to watch and listen to even
when it sounds too sexy today for
scratching peach but we love you guys
thank you for hanging out with us have a
great week and please don't donate us no
you shouldn't hate us because we'll be
back with a vengeance my floor whisper
next week no or Briones we're back to
normal he will be whisper baby come on
because seriously I'm actually really
proud of both of us or not I am us you
know laughing don't ruin it I wasn't
ruining it I was just saying we'll be
back next week with more whispering like
you've never oh but we won't we'll be
back with speaking loudly from now on
entire twitch stream will be whispers
only and so will my channel its hold
Julian's vlogs okay I guess you know I
guess you late cause I'll take a sound
guys have a great week
see you on the twitch stream tonight see
you on the blogs in Jenna's video
later guys bye guys